si on voyage deux fois par année on
habite notre maison au quotidien j'en
comprends que vous vous intéressez
monsieur jacquet particulièrement aux
mesures qu'on peut prendre lors de la
construction d'une maison lors de la
rénovation d'une maison donnez-nous dont
deux trois trucs dit comme ça pour que
si on a des raynaud affaires au cours
des prochains mois on puisse être un peu
outil qu'est un peu peut-être
il ya beaucoup de mises en chantier au
québec à chaque année au canada à
travers à travers notre pays on rénove
beaucoup et on construit beaucoup mais
c'est ça on rénove beaucoup plus qu'on
construit du neuf
ok donc beaucoup plus de travail à faire
au niveau de la rénovation puis
peut-être un des points un des points
qu'on oublie parfois laisser notre
gestion des déchets chaque fois qu'on
fait notre cuisine ben on prend un gros
paquet déchets pour mais c'est dans
l'eau dans nos poubelles et ses
poubelles boys ont possiblement deux
chemins ils s'en vont se faire enfouir
où ils s'en vont se faire brûler dans
les deux cas va il va y avoir soin du
co2 soit du méthane qui vote émis puis
un gros danger pour pour nous pour notre
production de ges donc quand on quand on
fait nos rénovations ou quand on pense à
changer de bâtiment ou à construire
bâtiment d'y aller avec des choix qui
vont être qu'ils vont durer dans le
temps
pas forcément suivre la dernière mode de
la cuisine rouge brillante qui serait
plus la mode dans trois ans on va devoir
mettre ce dialogue avec des choix
intelligents puis comme comme mes
collègues disait le but n'est pas
d'avoir de changer complètement notre
mode de vie pilote de vivre dans une
société contraignant qui diront pas plus
l'avion rénove plus c'est juste de deux
pauses il pourrait le compte de tous les
gestes puis je pense que beaucoup
d'options aujourd'hui on peut aller
choisir un matériel plus plus vert qu'un
autre on peut choisir d'acheter un
produit qui fabriqué dans la région
localement plutôt que celui qui est
importé parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut se
faire faire une cuisine qui est monté en
plus en europe chipé en voisine lui par
simon pas le maître de bateaux baisse à
ça s'additionne aux pois dgs des
matériaux qui ont été extraits souvent
en dehors de notre territoire les pays
où est-ce que ça a été fait e sont
électrifiées ou
on energy utilisent des énergies
fossiles pour pour ses lectrices y est
et donc tout ça s'accumule sur nos gs
c'est vrai que moi au jour le jour j'ai
ma cuisine puis j'ai des lumières au del
damas dans ma cuisine mais si j'ai fait
venir ma cuisine d'europe 1 dans mon
poids de grs mondiale binger tout le
trajet que mes matériaux en fait qui
s'additionnent dans mon empreinte donc
penser un peu à nos choix pour que l'or
je reviens à l'exemple de cuisine mais
pourquoi on soit contente de cuisine
pendant des années des années qu'on
n'est pas le goût de la changer
deux ans plus tard et puis et puis si on
doit absolument jeter des objets jetés
des matériaux ben le faire de façon
responsable aujourd'hui on a des centres
de tri on a des compagnies spécialisées
qui récupère des matériaux on peut
acheter les matériaux recyclés on peut
décider d'acheter des matériaux quand
contenu recyclé si on n'est pas à l'aise
avec du vieux bois on peut quand même
acheter du bois qui contient des
vieilles matière est donc juste en
faisant ces petits gestes là bas on
contribue largement diminuer la quantité
d'énergie consommée est ce que ce sont
des gestes qui coûte ne ferment plus
cher habituellement la balle quand on
veut vendre notre salade c'est sûr qu'on
dit que non dans les faits les dernières
statistiques en fait que j'ai que j'ai
présentée à mes étudiants récemment
c'était sur un bâtiment leed un bâtiment
leed platine on entend ça ici c'est un
bâtiment leed entre autres bâtiments
leed coûtera environ 5 à 6 % plus cher à
fabriquer ok est-ce qu'on rentre dans
notre argent a pris un certain nombre
d'années très rapidement ok si je vous
dis que même par exemple vous êtes 60%
plus économes en électricité de 60%
d'économie que vous faites à chaque
année bas c'est de l'argent que vous
gardez dans vos poches
si je vous dis que les matériaux on va
être beaucoup plus durable du plan celle
ci sur le plancher par exemple comme ici
en béton je vous dis que vous êtes bon
pour 50 ans vers ce plancher flottant en
plastique est de ne pas changer le
plancher à chaque et 10 ans ou bleu loup
le tapis c'est encore de l'argent qui
rentre dans vos qui reste dans vos
poches donc ou oui un petit sur cour et
des fois j que d'un niveau au niveau
résidentiel on arrive à faire des
bâtiments écologiques 11,0 sur coup
alors oui peut-être un mini sûr qu'au
départ mais
le retour sur investissement se fait
assez rapidement